ich bin ziemlich frech wie ein kleiner
kakadu hallo mein name ist luca und
momentan gibt es eine serie die extremen
kraft im hype ist und zwar zu how to
handle oder auf deutsch finger weg
genannt ich habe keine ahnung wer da die
titel übersetzt auf jeden fall haben die
schauspieler dieser serie innerhalb von
nur wenigen tagen millionen follower auf
instagram gemacht alle meine freunde
haben das schon gesehen und sie ziehen
spiel minecraft sonderschauen sie jetzt
mal die erste folge von finger weg
zusammen an
netflix es keine werbung übrigens nichts
bezahlt hier
okay wir sind am strand jetzt eine
hängematte anteile dem paradies mit
diesen leuten
ok
[Musik]
jesus ist auch dabei und nistet auf 640
moment
da sind leute auf einer paradiesischen
insel dürfen aber keinen bart unsere
ahnungslosen singles kennen zu lernen
den anfang nach dieser schönen hocker
könnte setzt ich nicht wieder so direkt
mache ja nicht machen kannst du mir
denkt dass mal ein bisschen alt
[Musik]
hallo ich bin chloe 20 und ein kleines
dummchen also hab geduld mit mir und ich
bin nicht die hexe leuchten
[Musik]
wollte sie nicht kennt dies durch die
hetze leuchte im buch alles klappt
dating ist für mich wie ein nebenjob ich
bin echt süchtig danach
was machen sie so hauptberuflicher
datenklau unsere nicht alle hält
beleuchte buch die lernen sich jetzt
alle kämen in den steuerberater deines
lebens
ich bin lange bucht kennt ihr den hier
das bugatti schon was der mensch wir
stoßen einfach auf schöne menschen auf
die lampen im buch finde man kann nie
genug optionen haben deshalb die zum
sport ersatz spieler und meine bank ist
folgen
peschawar vergleicht frauen mit einer
ersatzbank
ist da noch platz für eine lampe aus dem
buch oder most besonders stolz bin ich
auf mein
[Musik]
wo bin ich hier gelandet dre damals neu
muss er gucken welche lampe man hier ein
kontinent der dritte person kommt an
david und ich mag tattoos
als cashbulls blog
und
ja ich war tattoos
101 auf dem rücken könnt ihr sehen
[Musik]
welche sprache ist das weiß nicht
dann denkst du dass geht die noch dümmer
guck mal was ist das für eine sprache
ich weiß nicht was steht da drauf weiß
ich über adresse vom im buchgeschäft mit
lampen ich bin öfter verbindungs partys
vor jener mega besoffen ist okay ein
mädel hat sich mal das gelegt worden
sind größer nein deine sind unterhalten
also fast überschwänglich die
unterhalten sich über ihre ich glaube
dass ich mit meinen mann als jeder
himmels play wird und harry diese kommt
wieder zusammen
die ersten reihen seinen eigenen dings
bekommen hier unser bugatti wir unsere
halle davids und unsere lampe und die
arbeiten gehen sie zu zweit ein bisschen
veräppelt vorkommen akzente machen ich
schwach
akzente
es gibt leute die stehen er das gesicht
ein paar jahre auf innere werte oder auf
pro oder so media der harry der steht
auf akzente 11 bagger auf promi babes an
zum beispiel die kardashian scandal habe
ich geschrieben hallo mein putter
hinziehen
[Musik]
was
ich bin ziemlich frech
du ja da steht kendall jenner bestimmt
drauf auf party ist manchmal ganz laut
irgendwas rugby rugby harry ist so ein
bisschen das schwarze schaf
aber jetzt nicht schlimm wir haben eine
lampe dabei die klinik kann ich ja
wieder hell machen dann komm mädels und
wollen planschen ich kann nicht oft
genug hier durch bei zimmer laufen und
mir denken was ist das hier
harry gehen auf partys wo er rugby
schreit und dann kommen mädels an und
wollen mit ihm grenzen gehen
stellt man den anderen typen vorbild
werden hat der hat jetzt creme mit und
erkennt so schön
also es eine taktik ist sonnencreme
dabei haben da wird er direkt die mädels
eincremen kann und im hintergrund des
harry so geht mit mir bronze und neu
kommt so richtig zum strahlen denn es
dunkel wird david beschreiben
david vielleicht mit einem vorn haben
das werde man anfangen ich habe keine
masche oder so ich komme den klub und
die man herrn tauss kommt die nächste wo
ich nein die ist nicht mal deine
spezialschiffs gab und das nicht ist gut
die wirklich sonne wie kim kardashian
meine persönlichkeit ist das beste an
mehr viele götter mir auf dem posten
aber mein gesicht ist auch nicht
schlecht und super
persönlichkeiten oder hasst experten
ich denke ständig über alles nach gut
haben wir alles geklärt
jetzt gehts weiter mit ronda und auch
wieder noch eine nicole war ich zeigen
die zwischendurch mal diese deckel amt
da entdeckt man ich hasse solche bücher
wir sind fast vollzählig fehlt nur noch
sehr gut aus london
das voll aus
voll cool hier
wirklich voll cool hier
die konkurrenz ist mir egal ich bin das
alphamännchen auch dieses tattoo nicht
der löwen ist mein lieblingsfilm meine
auch ein bisschen verknallt in dich
nennen ob kann allein bin kein
beziehungs typ aber hat immer was am
laufen
ich bin auch kein beziehungs typ aber
habe
im laufen mit wie vielen frauen nicht
geschlafen habe es weniger als 1000
[Musik]
es gab doch nie irgendwas was ich mir
angeschaut habe wo ich so oft das
bedürfnis hatte mich vom scream zu
entfernen und nicht einfach nur hier
hinzustellen auf abstand
und wegen
bild einfach aus meinen gedanken löschen
haben die teilnehmer dieser stolz auf
jeden fall heute schon mal alle kennen
gelernt und es zeigt mir einfach dass
ich die serie nicht weiter gucken will
dann ist das video allerdings gefallen
hat und die unbedingt sehen wollen wie
es mit clown der lampe weiter geht oder
ihr wissen wollt wie oft harry rugby
schreien wird dann lasst einen daumen
hoch unter dem video daten schreibt
immer unten in die kommentare
ob die bock auf einen zweiten teil
hättet wie ich auf diese serie reagiere
ich hab da eigentlich keinen bock drauf
aber irgendwie war es schon unterhaltsam
jetzt befinden wir uns ja allerdings
auch im auto meine lieben freund und
wenn ihr noch kein abonnent von meinem
kanal seid könnt ihr gern da oben mal
auf den smiley draufklicken dass es
kostet und verpasst keine videos mehr
und hier ist ein video verlinkt das
soeben auf meinem 2 kanal online
gegangen ist und zwar eine neue das
video endet wenn challenge rugby